In Yemen, Houthi rebels claimed responsibility for the drone attacks...
...on vital oil installations that temporarily shut one down...
...and says that they are ready to carry out more attacks.
In Pakistan, a Pakistani Taliban militant group claimed responsibility...
...for the bombing late Monday in the southwest...
...that killed at least four policemen and injured around 10 other people.
In Sri Lanka, a wave of violence targeting Muslims...
...hit parts of the country this week,...
...with mosques and shops owned by Muslims ransacked and sometimes destroyed.
In Colombia, experts fear an uptick in stateless babies...
...born to parents who fled unrest in neighboring Venezuela...
...may lack key rights in adulthood if the conflict drags on for years...
...and they are unable to return.
Finally from Bosnia-Herzegovina, homes and roads have been flooded...
...after rivers broke their banks following heavy rains,...
...triggering concerns of a repeat of floods five years ago when dozens of people died.